- You go first.
(upbeat music)
- Potentially, there could
be some controversial,
like, things we haven't even eaten before,
so I'm pretty excited.
- I'm kinda nervous.
- Bring it on, Philippines.
We're ready.
- [Man] So this is sisig.
- Pig ears, immediately turns me off.
- [Man] It looks like something
that I have eaten before
at around two, three AM in the morning.
- Smell's super fragrant.
- Cheers.
- But it's very rubbery.
And very soft.
- That's really good.
- [Man] Yeah.
- If no one told me that
this was the ear of a pig,
I'd just be like, "Yeah,
I'm just eating bacon."
- I don't think there's
any way I would order
that off a menu if I saw a pig's ear,
but upon tasting it, it's
definitely something I'd go again.
- Thanks, Filipinos.
I now have eaten pig's ears.
- Are they like a super food?
Will I get like really good skin?
- Chicken adobo.
No I can't say that.
That sounds so bogan.
- Oh, I can smell it already.
It's something mysterious about this one.
I'm nervous.
- You're nervous?
It's just chicken!
- It tastes like teriyaki chicken,
like you know the chicken
inside the sushi rolls?
- Yeah, I know all of that.
- Yeah.
- I think it's really good.
I think that this is a hero.
- Sinigang na Hipon.
It's like clars?
- There are two huge prawns
in the middle of this bowl.
I honestly wouldn't even
know how to shell a prawn.
- Okay.
- I'm such a bad Australian.
- Smells a bit like an aquarium.
- Alright.
- Sweat from a boot poured
into a bowl (laughs).
- Sweat from a boot?
- So if you're sitting
down, eating this soup,
you're gonna be like eating soup,
but then also shelling prawns,
and then going back to eating a soup.
- It's just a tasty prawn.
- Imagine eating this on a first date.
And you have to get
your hands in your soup
and peel all these prawns
in front of someone.
- It's a no for me.
- So this is kare-kare,
and this is bagoong.
And this is like shrimp paste, apparently.
And this is oxtail, and ox tripe.
It actually just smells
like peanut butter.
- Oh, that's rubbery.
- It's so chewy.
- Is that fur on it still?
- To be honest, I don't
know what an ox is.
- I think the ox is okay.
- Look, everything else
so far has been great,
but just, let's skip the tripe next time.
- So this is dinuguan
and it's pig's blood.
- [Woman] At least it's not like red.
You know what, if you haven't
told me that was pig's blood,
I'd be like, "Oh yeah,
I'd eat more of that."
- I think the blood made
the dish more exciting.
- And there's a certain
smell to it as well
that you can smell even
when it's in your mouth.
- That look's a mess.
Tastes a treat.
- I would not have this again,
because it's (bleep) terrifying.
- I would order it for sure.
- Would you like the bin?
- Oh you want the bin.
- I don't like it.
- After today, I was
actually kind of impressed.
I thought I'd hate everything.
- Some unique ingredients.
- I think that Filipinos
are courage as (bleep)
for some of the food that
they put in their mouths.
- But on the whole,
actually completely delish.
(pop music)